no i know you're unemployed
but i i still stand by this point
there's no excuse for you to dress like
a substitute teacher
your friend makes clothes
[Laughter]
he makes interesting and i've given him
stuff before too yeah but that's the
problem you choose to wear like a
waterproof button up
[Music]
this is what he was wearing on
thursday yeah basically on your june
event yeah so like i was getting ready
and i've been dating my fiance for 15
years so she knows like how i look and
how i dress so when i showed her my
outfit she was like wow you look good
because like i usually just like
obviously really [ __ ] no i mean like she
just sees me every day you should not
bury her enough she loves me for who i
am right but so i showed her my
substitute teacher outfit she's like wow
you look good so i get to the event and
like i'm you know i'm dressed like
whatever and noel comes up and he's like
dude what the [ __ ] are you wearing man
like my confidence is just like oh
dude what the f
why are you [ __ ] here man you're so
old where's your wife go home to your
family dude bro that is so funny that's
so mean
and keep going
to an event like damn my fiance's
digging what i'm wearing i'm feeling
good what the [ __ ] are you wearing how
was your did you like your event you had
fun like i had a blast man i like i was
on cloud nine on youtube
i was like [ __ ] getting was it i was
getting down really i was i
i drank
for the first time in 108 days i was
gonna i was like i'm gonna i'm gonna do
it i gotta have some of my own drink i
regret it 100 you regretted it oh my god
the next day i was just like i just
bottoms up
and the double laps you seem totally
fine
i know but it just i don't know i was
like i don't [ __ ] whatever the drinks
were a little sugary the ones that they
were handing out yeah not that i had
like nine not the june shine june shine
is good
milfs dig it and you will too so the
dance floor was dry okay right and then
cash us
[ __ ] started it
so there's like a dj booth that was not
used at the time like sitting by the uh
whatever area and we found this
microphone and we were just like
pretending we were just like [ __ ]
like singing the songs and [ __ ] like
that and we were getting down and then
um noel made the comment about my that
was when noel made the comment about my
office
but you were feeling extra good i was
funny too i was [ __ ] like doing my
dance moves and i was like yo what are
you wearing
you're going over you're thinking he's
gonna like compliment you on the dance
move yeah i must be killing it right now
wants to say something
what is it man i know
you want dance that's a shirt
you need to change
keep in mind too like i was looking like
[ __ ] at this time because i was drenched
in sweat my hair is all like [ __ ]
everywhere like i know i was looking
like [ __ ] at this time and that was when
noel was like dude like we gotta [ __ ]
get you dressing better dude i don't
know what the [ __ ] you're wearing
but yeah great event though i want
better for you yeah
yeah i was going to say i was going to
ask you
what have you had these 511s since like
2015 i still wear my high school shirts
that's i know you do i
know you i still wear my foot i went to
foothill high school i still have
foothill baseball
okay that's what i wear like an approach
here we can give you i haven't closed
right over there i don't know we need to
get away from that okay because he
dresses like you wear a shirt from
t-shirt cannons
where you know the developers you know
the developers that those guys that we
would work with oh yeah we're only
someone on the boardwalk shot that one
at you
dude
my first time visiting california
i know you took a [ __ ] venice beach
tour just to get that t-shirt at the end
and you were like [ __ ] yeah
but you you thrift a lot right i love
goodwill so what are you doing
people who thrift look good
wow 511. you're buying this sail rack at
the thrift store
no way do you have these here
dude i used to wear these these are mine
my family had to get rid of these during
the housing process but i want them back
you guys remember nike roches yes and
like how everyone was clowning oh dude
yeah there was one time this is when i
was living with zach he's like dude i
know you like shoes and stuff i got the
craziest sneakers ever like you're gonna
love it comes out of his room brings the
box i opened up the black version okay
zach i'm not some fashion forward dude
but if i were to style you in any way i
would like let's start from top to
bottom you should see my running outfits
my running outfits are horrendous the
reason why i'm running is because i got
fired and have like this free time and
usually people when they get fired they
get like a better job just to show the
company and like the only thing i'm
going to show to them is like i can run
six miles now
you don't want to hire me back
and i rise i run by my boss's house too
so like i if i ever run into her what
yeah
wait i know where she lives she was just
my neighbor it's not any i'm not like
weird like that but like
that that was
i purposely have been running six miles
no her house it's like some forrest gump
[ __ ] her house is the end of the run so
he like runs and he lands in her front
yard just stands in front of her ring
camera
[Music]
and then turns around you know how
people touch like something just to make
sure that they hit the mark and then
turn around i like touch her front door
i'm like all right
[Laughter]
i still have no money because what are
you wearing yeah yeah she's like zach
yes
change that [ __ ] outfit
i've been working there for five years
too so like they already was working
there and so they i've i had like every
outfit like i wear all the time i wear
the same jeans every day like my buddy
would be like oh you're wearing the
[ __ ] venice shirt today for example
yep is that a shirt that you wear no
this is pretty awesome that's new
[Laughter]
is that goodwill
uh you're sure that's new no this was
actually at like venice beach like i
went to bed oh you went to the wait you
went to the boardwalk to buy that my mom
my mom and sister visited me during my
chemo so if you guys can back off for a
second
did they buy you that shirt and then
push you down a hill
[Laughter]
[ __ ]
suck let's just help him out it looks
like i'm like close to death like with
my office no but they visited me and uh
my sister just wanted to get a shirt and
i was like oh this one's nice so i
bought it oh my [ __ ] god did you is
there did you hit the cutoff for
make-a-wish no i was one stage away yeah
i could have been stage three i couldn't
anybody say three i would say [ __ ] that
you know you could you could lean like a
very trendy thing now it's just like
basic like button-ups you know with
undershirts i feel like that's like a
natural look oh you're actually giving
him like real yeah and [ __ ] get in
some like like slacks or something okay
but so the reason why i wear goodwill
clothes is because i sweat really badly
that's why so like explains the hands
embrace it okay tight under armour gray
shirts
light gray
like really embracing nipples pointing
yeah hey
i know a thing or two about some hard
nipples man do you have hard nibs yeah
yeah i got diamond cutters man
do your nipples chafe when you run yeah
they do dude that [ __ ] is
i chase right here my one ball yeah i
get brutal niffle that should be that
chase that should be like a torture
mechanism yeah it should be what yeah oh
he's he's been through the ringer don't
worry about it yeah okay
yeah whatever that means
like what would they do like they would
just take your nipples
cheese
it's really fast
you